jetzt bei mir zu gast der ukrainische
aussenminister dimitris mister cool the
world germany ist willkommen in
deutschland
sie haben sich gerade in berlin mit
außenminister heiko maas betroffen
sie haben die bilder aus berlin gesagt
überrascht
die menschen sind überall gleich hier
versuchen die menschen den sommer
genießen
natürlich müsst sie einschränkungen
beachten
das ist die entscheidung wer wo
sicherheit oder
jeder muss für sich selber entscheiden
doch der korona virus ist überall wir
müssen richtig sein doch wir gehören so
einer generation wo sie dicht daneben
genießt und einschränkungen deswegen ist
natürlich schwierig und in germany aber
keine mannschaft hat auch crooner
partnern deutschland die vor mit
aufgrund von krone nicht viel aus der
ehemalige kanzler schröder hat ihren
gesellschafter als zwerg bezeichnet du
sollst können das ist ein zeichen der
schwäche beim warten auf anstatt auf
argumente natürlich stehe ich meine
botschaft
er hat die wahrheit verteidigt diese
jugend war die rolle von den spdlern der
russischen bürger schröder hat das was
er aber das recht stark und julia krumm
hat er das so gesagt in wersen wenn sie
keine argumente für ihre position haben
müssen auch leidigen der sprache
zurückblicken ich hoffe herr schröder
kann es aus dem gesamten reisen und die
diskussionen
ein bisschen schulleben der europäischen
standards an
da spielt die angst dass wieder ein
großes thema
deutschland ist besonders wichtig ist
bei dem persönliche meinung ist dead
space
leider müssen wir hier den europäischen
regeln die und energiemarkt zählen wir
auf gerechtigkeit und sie haben recht
menschen sperren mensch ich dasselbe
getan
umgekehrt ständen gibt weil wir die
ausbreitung des virus von optivo coreg
jobs am vw zudem wird kiel krieg leider
nichts drauf gehalten und werden
weiterhin getötet es gibt den
scharfschützen der bei den fans in what
you think ist es wird sich der krieg in
den letzten jahren verändert
was ist ihrer meinung nach die strategie
vom russischen präsidenten gibt es
überhaupt ein interesse am frieden oder
könnte es zu einer weiteren eskalation
kommen
grundsätzlich nehmen wir an dass
russland am frieden interessiert ist
ansonsten macht es für die russische
föderation keinen sinn sich auf
verhandlungen mit uns ein zu lassen aber
die gesamtstrategie ist eine offene
runde auf dem körper der ukraine zu
lassen
entweder um uns dabei zu helfen die
wunde zu heilen wenn russland glaubt
dass es an der zeit ist konstruktiv zu
sein oder um noch mehr salz in die wunde
zu streuen und für mehr schmerz und
leiden zu sorgen wenn sie glauben dass
das die effizientere strategie ist für
einige monate vom letzten sommer des
jahres ende war russland konstruktiver
und uns war es gelungen uns auf einige
deals mitteln zu einigen
aber seit januar merken wir dass
russland langsam ins neue konstruktive
zurückfällt und es immer schwerer wird
mit ihnen zusammenzuarbeiten
aber wir halten weiter daran fest und es
sind unsere leute unser land und wir
werden alles tun was in unserer macht
steht um es weiter inne zu haben und
unser volk zu schützen
meine letzte frage herr außenminister
bezieht sich nicht auf den krieg sondern
auch bilder aus kiew die wir gesehen
aber es in side hotel rooms in germany
we say leihmutter warten darauf ihre
babys dort abzuholen
dort sieht man baby ist ein hotelzimmer
und deutsche paare die darauf warten die
babys aus der ukraine nach deutschland
zu holen
erklären sie uns diese situation
nach ukrainischen gesetze sind
leihmutterschaften erlaubt der situation
auf dem foto kam es aufgrund der
aktuellen corona krise die reisewarnung
und flugstreichungen haben das
verursacht aber als wir im
außenministerium von dem ausmaß des
problems gehört haben haben wir sofort
ein prozess entwickelt der es eltern
erlaubt trotz reisewarnung in die
ukraine einzureisen und ihre babys
abzuholen
denn für uns ist das glück der kinder
und das der eltern das wichtigste wenn
also deutsche eltern ihre kinder aus der
ukraine holen wollen müssen sie nach
einreise nicht in quarantäne und können
mit ihren babys sofort nach deutschland
zurück es gibt einen speziellen prozess
sie müssen sich beim auswärtigen amt in
der ukraine melden und dann ermöglichen
wir ihnen die einreise und sie bereiten
sich zu hause darauf vor
danach können sie mit dem kind zurück
fliegen es ist eine sensible und
humanitäre frage und wir versuchen sie
bestmöglich zu behandeln